الا وزير الخارجيه تركيه مولود شاؤوس
اوغلو ان بلاده مسرور بالتدابير الاخيره
لسويد لمكافحه ما وصافه بالارهاب مطالبان
السويد بمزيد من الخطوات الملموسه جاء هذا
في مؤتمر صحفي للوزير التركيه مع نظيره
السويدي
يا سلام
عن المنظمات الارهابيه ولبعض الخطوات
السويديه ومنها اعاده احد منتسبي حزب
العمال لتركيا هذه خطوات في الاتجاه
الصحيحه لكنه وعلى صعيدي اعاده الاشخاص
المرتبطين بالمنظمات الارهابيه او تجميد
اصول المنظمات الارهابيه فانه لم تحدث
تطورات ايجابيه بهذا الخصوص لقد سلمنا
السويد قائمه باسماء الارهابيين الذين
نطالب بهم ولم يتم التسليم من السلبي جدا
ان تصدر المحكمه العليا في السويد قرارا
برفض طلب تركيا باعاده احد منتسبي تنظيم
فتح الله جولن ونحن مطالب بان ينفذ
البلدان السويد وفي لندن تعاهداتهم
الوارده في الاتفاق الثلاثي فيما يتعلق
بتسليم المطلوبين طلبنا طبيعيه جدا ونابع
من الاتفاقيه الثلاثيه
جديد بصوا لس باش تايجر
سن تشريعات لمكافحه الارهاب في اطار
الاتفاق الثلاثي الموقع بين بلاده وتركيا
وفنلندا
مكافحه الارهاب لدينا بما يتماشى والاتفاق
الثلاثي وابتداء من الاول من يناير كانون
الثاني 2023 سيتم العمل بالتعديل الدستوري
الذي سيتيح لنا الطبيق على حريه الضلوع في
الارهاب او دعمه بالتاكيد حزب العمال
الكردستاني وتنظيم الدوله ستاثراني بهذه
التغييرات بالاضافه لذلك سيتم تعريف جرائم
اخرى في الدستور ومنها ان الناس ايواء او
اخفاء الاشخاص الظالمين في الدعايه
لتنظيمات الارهابيه او دعمها او الترويجي
للانضمام لها نحن نتخذ تدابير ملموسه في
اتجاه الوفاء بتعهداتنا تجاهها لاتفاقيه
الثلاثيه